I'm an American in every sense of the
word I know cardi B in what country this
possible you come from Africa and you're
in Hollywood now
all my life I've kind of like hidden
might put my immigration status and it
wasn't until they decided to cancel it
that I was like look I can't be scared
anymore I can't hide in the shadows
anymore I'm in Black Panther I'm in the
good place and I feel like to whom much
is given much as we expected or required
so I decided to use my voice and to
amplify the message and to actually put
a face to the this real political issue
that a lot of people don't understand or
know about I'm a dreamer meaning I'm a
daca recipient this is the third action
for childhood arrivals that Obama's sign
as an executive order in 2012 Trump
administration decided to cancel a back
in September
there's not a day that undocumented
people go without a thought of possibly
being torn away from everything that
they love from their family from the
life that they've built here because
sometimes just a minor technicality you
don't renew your visa and all the sudden
you're rendered illegal you can't adjust
your status to anything else like I came
here when I was 10 years old with my
parents seeking political asylum fleeing
war and now I'm on daca and I've been in
this country 25 years and my whole life
I just thought I could achieve a lot of
success I could just be great at
everything that I do try to be a model
citizen give back to the community and
then eventually the thing will work
there just seems like there's no door
there's no way to actually adjust the
status I've tried everything people are
like well you didn't do this no I've
seen as many lawyers as possible I'm
doing everything that you can humanly do
just so that I can have the peace of
mind that you know I'm gonna be okay and
my family won't be torn apart we're not
murderers or killer so we're not trying
to take away from America we love
America we just want an opportunity to
have a permanent solution we want
Congress to finally pass a DREAM Act
[Music]
America is at a crossroad and Americans
have a decision to make as far as like
what country does America wanna be
Americans have been able to break walls
of race of gender inequality of
disability of just so many amazing
things which makes this country great
that's that's the America that I love
and I believe and I want to remain
[Music]
[Music]